[Musik]
georgien an der schwarzmeerküste unsere
zweite reise etappe beginnt auf dem
hafengelände von batumi ihres vieles in
bewegung der hafen ist stark gewachsen
und darauf ist der betriebsleiter stolz
werde immer wichtigeren at der großen
seidenstraße meint er
in unserer ersten folge sind wie er von
verdächtigen nach istanbul dann quer
doch die türkei bis hierher nach batumi
gereizt
das ist baumaterial sagt dennis marzahn
iz baumaterial wert hier dringend
benötigt bei georgien ganze stadtteile
neu gebaut werden
ich liebe meine arbeit weil wir hier an
einem der wichtigsten orte wirken die es
in unserer geschichte gegeben hat der
hafen von batumi gehört zu den weltweit
ältesten in der geschichte den gibt es
bereits seit dem zweiten jahrhundert
nach christus die weiterentwicklung
georgiens aber auch die geschicke in
unseren nachbarländern armenien und
aserbaidschan hänge nicht zuletzt von
diesem mehr anschluss ab und wir sind
daran die umschlags möglichkeiten hier
dauernd zu verbessern
die ware kommt aus dem westen
geld ist vorhanden vor allem weil das
land stark vom geldsegen westlicher
entwicklungsorganisationen profitiert
die georgier gelten als geschäftstüchtig
das zeigt sich auch hier bei diesen
containern aus ihnen werden zuerst mal
gebraucht waren vorwiegend aus
deutschland hervorgezaubert
doch nicht nur das
die autos sind gefüllt mit allen
schnäppchen die der westen zu bieten hat
kleidung fernsehgeräte velos spielbar
bei der einfuhr werden nur die autos
selbst verzollt nicht aber das was sich
in ihnen drin befindet
pfiffige importeure nutzen die autos
deshalb auch als transportbehälter und
überhaupt der handel mit dem
gebrauchtwagen ist mittlerweile zum
zweitwichtigsten wirtschaftsfaktor
georgiens geworden
die georgische hafenstadt batumi eine
bewegte geschichte sie ist einst von
kriegen gegründet worden war unter
anderem mal unter britischer kontrolle
und zuletzt teil der sowjetunion viele
sowjetbürger strömten damals in den
sommermonaten in die ferien heim ins
schwarze meer
georgien war so was wie das italien der
sowjetunion in den letzten jahren ist
batumi rigoros ausgebaut worden vor
allem reiche türken werden in die neuen
casinos und fünfsternhotels gelockt auf
mich wirkt die stadt wie ein
potemkinsches dorf eine kulisse welche
die wirkliche situation der stiftung des
landes kaschiert es braucht mut um
diesen bau waren der georgischen elite
zu kritisieren und diesen mut hat eine
zierliche frau die ich in batumi treffe
foto raths ist journalistin und eine der
wenigen opposition stimmen im land sie
kennt keine tabus und kritisiert mal die
konservative haltung der archäologische
orthodoxen kirche dann die vom
staatspräsidenten geförderten
prunkbauten
wo immer man hinschaut zentrum von
batumi sprießen neubauten aus dem boden
die einfachen bürgerinnen und bürger
profitierten kaum von diesen
investitionen sagt bratzel
und die hätten auch nichts zu sagen
rücksichtslos verfolgten reiche
investoren und hohe beamte ihre eigenen
ziele
viele bürger haben protestiert haben
unterschriften gesammelt
einen baustopp verlangt geklagt aber man
hat ihnen gesagt dass alles ganz nach
den gesetzen verlaufen
[Musik]
historische gebäude werden abgerissen
oder ausgehöhlt und bunte plakate künden
weitere bauvorhaben an
[Musik]
hier verlautete 1 dieses gebäude
jüngst wurde ist seine art lustschloss
umgebaut
einige in batumi behaupten der
umtriebige staatspräsident saakaschwili
habe dieses schlösschen für sich selbst
reserviert
auch die tore schließt das nicht aus
[Musik]
die vielen abbrucharbeiten schock ihr
mich was ist das ziel so nah tommy anni
art disney welten stehen des weges stand
früher hier ihr stand mal unser
postgebäude was jetzt seinem hobby
weichen muss
wenn man sich auch nur ein paar hundert
meter auf den stadtzentrum hinaus bewegt
in die wohnviertel zu machen diese einen
armseligen eindruck fast die hälfte der
bevölkerung ist arbeitslos
viele menschen scheinen zu resignieren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir verlassen die stadt am schwarzen
meer und fahren in die bergwelt der
georgischen region abchasien
von batumi zuerst ein stück weit hoch
richtung golderze pass
[Musik]
hier im wilden bergtal treffen wir auf
ein ganz anderes georgien die menschen
die von einer bescheidenen
landwirtschaft leben wirken besonders
selbstbewusst
alle heute ist hier am berg sind
ausgebucht wir würden aber trotzdem eine
unterkunft finden hat man uns
versprochen
im bergdorf hollo noch vor der passhöhe
betreiben nämlich der polizeichef mit
der vermietung von gästebetten ein
nebengeschäft
so wie hier bereit sind hühner sind ja
richtig wir sollen uns auf dem
polizeiposten melden
und schon kommt uns in zivilkleidung zum
ball quads entgegnet er führt uns zu
seinem haus in dem wir für eine nacht
unsere betten beziehen
das haus hat er zum teil selbst gebaut
was sie war
die betten stehen bereit da sehr viele
gäste schauen hier wohl kaum vorbei ich
bin nicht der polizeichef hier mord
sondern ermittler
meine frau ist kinderärztin und dies ist
unser heim und sie beherbergen immer
wieder gäste nicht immer aber ab und zu
manchmal meldet sich jemand sucht nach
einem dach überm kopf
aber weil er ausser haus arbeiten sind
wir natürlich nicht immer hier
wer meldet sich denn hier können die
verschiedensten leute seien
erholung finden durchreisende touristen
die hier in der gegend nach einer
unterkunft suchen
[Musik]
uns gefällt's in kulow
und dann next morgen ist es schon hell
werde ich zu meiner überraschung von
joel und seine frau zum frühstück
eingeladen
beide sind geschäftstüchtig aber vor
allem auch sehr liebenswürdig radtour
ist dieser typische geschäft käsekuchen
caccia boris sind sehr bekömmlich sie
schmecken ähnlich wie die schweizer
käser will ist hier aufgewachsen
er fühlt sich ein dorf und der gegend
hier dank seinem optimismus hat raucht
schwierigere zeiten gut überstanden
das gemeinsame frühstück bietet
gelegenheit mehr über sein leben zu
erfahren
wenn ich mit früher vergleiche also
denke ich dass unser leben hier besser
geworden ist ich könnte ja auch nicht
alles hinschmeißen unser stadt oder
sonstwo leben
[Musik]
ich finde unser leben ist besser
geworden
amberg werden jetzt auch noch zwei
winterkurort zwei ski station gebaut und
bei uns eine neue kirche so was gab es
früher nicht
wir sprechen noch überdies und darf bis
jumbo mit einem dezidierten griff neben
seinem sessel greift ein cognac nach
meinem rezept lasst uns in probieren mit
45 prozent ist er nicht sehr
hochprozentig lasst uns trinken auf
deinen besuch auf ein langes leben hier
bei uns in dieser luft lebt man lange
bei euch wohl auch also auf die gäste
wer wollte dieser gastfreundschaft
wieder stehen jetzt in diesem moment
weiß ich noch nicht dass dies nicht das
letzte schnapsglas ist dass sich an
diesem vormittag in meinen händen halten
werde
jumbo jetzt in der polizeiuniform
begleitet mich nun prinz dorf am
kirchenneubau und an den läden und
straßenhändlern vorbei
roth
[Musik]
ist zur passhöhe auf 2025 metern ist es
noch ziemlich weit und die straße wird
immer schlechter
zu zeiten der sowjetunion war diese
gegend sperrgebiet sie bildete einst die
außengrenze zum nato land türkei
[Musik]
endlich erreichen wir die passhöhe die
gegend verlassen
lebensmittelpunkt für die härten für die
straßenarbeiten treffpunkt für
durchreisende bildet dieser kleine kiosk
wo ich mich in kürze mitten in einer
hochprozentigen trinkgelage wiederfinde
früher so erzählt mir diese härte seien
hier nie ausländer vorbeigekommen
deshalb müsse unsere einkehr nun
gefeiert werden
ehrensache einmal zweimal anstoßen
deshalb nicht der gastgeber aber lässt
nicht locker kost und nochmals prost auf
das wohl des landes auf das wohl der
frauen auf die freundschaft eine
verabschiedung ist nicht zu denken noch
nicht deshalb nochmal auf das wohl der
frauen auf unserem besuch auf die
zukunft auf die freundschaft zwischen
der schweiz und georgien irgendwann zum
glück holt mich mein team mit einer
gewissen schadenfreude hier wieder raus
nach einer ruppigen talfahrt erreichen
wir dass höhlenkloster von war zwar
deutlich wie sehr die konservative
georgisch orthodoxe kirche seit ein paar
jahren wieder an bedeutung und einfluss
gewonnen hat
es ist kalt frühmorgens im höhlenkloster
war ca
vater lasse beruf zur messe
[Musik]
seit über zehn jahren lebt der junge
mönch hier völlig abgeschieden im
gebirge zusammen mit neun anderen
männchen die sich für ein
entbehrungsreiches leben mit gott
entschieden haben früher wohnten
hunderte mönche in warza heute sind die
höhlen aus dem zwölften jahrhundert ein
zuhause für den 31-jährigen felsenfesten
glaubensbruder schon mit 18 19 wollte
ich münchen diesem kloster werden das
passierte sozusagen plötzlich ganz
plötzlich gelangte gott damals in mein
herz
die liebe zu gott und der wunsch mönch
zu werden
das kommt nicht einfach so das ist ein
geschenk etwas mystisches beruf ich
wurde mönche aus liebe zu meinem gott
mein land georgen und zu meinem volk
[Musik]
das kloster hat eine bewegte
vergangenheit es diente auch als grenz
festung zur türkei bis zu 50.000
menschen suchten hier immer wieder
zuflucht vor den vielen eroberern
georgiens
[Musik]
der steilen felswand wurden tunnel und
terrassen abgetrotzt
die höhlen räume sind auf sieben
stockwerken durch treppen leitern und
aquädukte wie ein labyrinth miteinander
verbunden
das quellwasser sei frisch und sprudel
wie vor 800 jahren sagt vatter lazar
einzig der strom ist hier neu aus
sowjetzeiten
damals galt religion als opium fürs volk
die mönche wurden umgebracht oder
deportiert und aus dem kloster machte
man ein museum
nach dem gebet treffen sich die mönche
zum frühstück das höhle leben ist hart
und bietet wenig abwechslung
doch vater lhasa und die anderen mönche
sind erfüllt von christentum und
vaterland sie beten taufen die kinder
der umliegenden dörfer und führen
trauungen und georgisch orthodoxe
gottesdienste durch für das leben in
meditation hat fatah azzam mit dem
bürgerlichen namen georges jorisch willi
als knapp 20-jähriger alles hinter sich
gelassen
die familie in tiflis sein jurastudium
seine freunde in seiner winzigen zelle
betet der tag für tag für sie und für
sein volk
nur zwei wochen pro jahr darf er das
kloster verlassen dann geht er wandern
und bergsteigen im wilden kaukasus
[Musik]
im winter sei es hier oben minus 25 grad
in seiner zelle werde es mit einem
strahler aber angenehme 15 grad über
null erzählte uns vater lazar ganz
zufrieden
die göttliche ruhe wird jedoch gestört
georgien möchte nämlich seine marode
wirtschaft durch den tourismus ankurbeln
auch hier hinten im tal seit der
politischen wende sind über 80 prozent
der georgier wieder orthodoxe christen
der glaube an gott boomt und das
interesse am höhlenkloster wächst für
die mönche bricht eine neue zeit an
früher kam niemand je und es gab
überhaupt nichts
auch keine straße heute hat sich die
infrastruktur für unser ganzes kloster
etwas verbessert für georgien ist der
tourismus gut war für uns ist die stille
besser
mit oder ohne touristen das wichtigste
für vater lassa bleibt in warza für sein
georgien zu beten
das jetzt aus seiner schwierigen
wirtschaftlichen situation heraus finden
will
[Musik]
wir reisen weiter die stadt box schumi
mit ihren mineralwasserquellen bis nach
korea geburtsstadt starten
die ausläufer des kaukasus sind am
horizont in der stadt zu sehen
die große stalin startete die einst hier
im zentrum stand hat man vor kurzem
entfernt
dass stalin museum in dem der sowjet
diktator seit jahrzehnten verherrlicht
wird hat sich zwar jüngst zum ziel
gesetzt verstärkt auch auf die probleme
des stalinismus hinzuweisen
davon aber ist bei unserem besuch wenig
spürbar
der personenkult ist noch immer um die
präsent und dies lässt sich auch nicht
beschönigen gewisse nationalkonservative
in russland und georgien verehren den
massenmörder nach wie vor
obwohl stalin mit seiner
nationalitätenpolitik die basis für die
jüngsten bürger kriege auf dem gebiet
der ehemaligen sowjetunion gelegt habe
auch in georgien selbst
[Musik]
um die folgen eines solchen konflikt
geht es auch hier mit einem team des
internationalen komitees vom roten kreuz
besuchen wir eine note siedlung welche
das ikk etwas außerhalb der stadt gori
für besonders bedürftige vertriebene aus
südossetien eingerichtet hat im sommer
vor viereinhalb jahren hat der georgien
seinen krieg gegen die separatistischen
osten verloren jetzt ist südossetien vom
übrigen georgien durch grenzsperren
getrennt die georgier die damals
vertrieben worden sind können nicht mehr
in ihre heimat zurück
[Musik]
über 10.000 solche notunterkünfte hand
hilfswerke im ganzen land errichtet
ebenerdige einfach ausgestattete häuser
shukpoli war josh willis 69 schüler
fetting hat mit ihrem mann an ethnischen
georgier in südossetien einen hof
betrieben
bei kriegsausbruch vor vier jahren ist
die flucht gelungen von ihrem mann aber
fehlt jede spur
bei ethnischen säuberungen ist er
wahrscheinlich getötet worden die
rentnerin ist froh dass sie hier
wenigstens ein dach über dem kopf hat
[Musik]
in ihrem bescheidenen heim lebt auch
nino die schwiegertochter ob sie sich
hier in dieser siedlung inzwischen zu
hause fühlen können möchten wir von der
vertriebenen wissen
nein das ist nicht mein eigentliches
zuhause
ich vermisse unser stück erde
meine leute gern wieder dort die
bürgerkriege der vergangenen jahrzehnte
haben viele georgierinnen und georgi
heimatlos gemacht viele sind auf hilfe
angewiesen und werden es noch lange sein
[Musik]
doch dieses bescheidene leben sei nicht
das schlimmste meinten sie das aller
schlimmste sei keine nachricht über den
vergleich ihres mannes zu haben
das ist hier schwierig diese
unsicherheit nicht zu wissen was war und
ist das belastet vor allem an religiösen
verehrter wenn andere auf den friedhöfen
blumen nieder
dann kann ich ja nirgendwo hin dann
fühle ich mich in der ungewissheit
verloren
schließlich wollte ich noch von ihr
wissen ob sie nach dem was ich wieder
fahren ist nicht manchmal auf rache
sinnt was geschehen ist ist geschehen
das war wohl schicksal musste wohl so
kommen
ich singe auf keine rache niemandem
gegenüber
es ist wichtig zu vergeben
die vertriebene ist eigentlich
südosseten aber sie kann nicht in ihr
dorf zurück sie würde dort verfolgt weil
sie mit einem ethnischen georgier
verheiratet war
wir verlassen die umgebung von gohouri
und verarbeiter in die georgische
hauptstadt tiflis
die stadt wehrt ähnlich wie batumi
modernisiert im zentrum führt eine
futuristische droht kleber die cura über
den größten fluss im kaukasus
[Musik]
der präsidentenpalast er zeugt von
selbstbewusstsein des gegenwärtigen
amtsinhabers
es sind aber vor allem die alten häuser
mit den balkonen und weintrauben die
verträumten plätze in der altstadt
welche tiflis zu einem ganz besonderen
juwel machen
[Musik]
immer wenn ich in tiflis bin besuche ich
meinen freund lasse bakradse ein
geistreicher mensch der im
literaturmuseum die bibliophilen schätze
des landes verwaltet
hier im museum hin bekannt die
erstaunlichsten dokumente wertvollen
aufschluss über das leben längst
erloschen seitenstraße geben
19 20 sind jahrhundert ist diese bibel
abgeschrieben im zwölften jahrhundert
auch berg athos in griechen das für
orthodoxie unheimlich wichtige ort ist
in welche sprach linie und ist natürlich
dass ich so evangeliar und das ist ein
einzelstück gibt es inzwischen ein
zustimmendes tour handel geschriebenes
so schaumann wie klein schläft ja auch
das fast eine lupe braucht man keinen
luca hat man gute augen damals gesagt du
kannst das letztlich kann das auch lesen
und das schöne glaube das ist wie
gestern geschrieben
nicht alles ist so gut erhalten wie
derzeit
und es gibt natürlich ließen bilder drin
die bilder sind auf 1500 dann ist es
später auch weiter bei geführt es war
sehr oft so dass in dieser zeit und
warte ich jetzt wunderbar
sascha ist auch ein georgischer patriot
und oft kommt in ihm wut hoch gegen das
einstige sowjet regime und gegen dessen
haupterben den russen woher kommt keine
wut gegen island gegenüber allem was
regeln möchte auch mit geprägt es waren
die mondlandung szene die mir wirklich
eingeprägt ist im kopf und die
mondlandung szene in der sowjetischen
fernsehen wurde gezeigt vielleicht passe
und entlang als ob es nichts besonderes
wäre und ich kann sehr gut erinnern mein
vater und ein freund und haben jetzt
haben wir dann wussten wir haben ja und
wenn man in so eine situation aufwächst
die ist natürlich sehr distanzierte
haltung zu russland und es ist
vielleicht für viele georgier und viele
sowjetische länder bürger nicht sehr
typisch aber für mich war das immer klar
dass diese so wird oder und zugrunde
geht
und ich war sehr froh dass es zugrunde
gegangen ist es gibt nicht mal ein
bisschen nostalgie und sie sondern auch
wirklich lernen eines wunderschönen
tagesumsatz gleichberechtigt nachbarn zu
akzeptieren und dann werden wir freunde
werden nach den parlamentswahlen vom
vergangenen oktober im wechsel in der
georgischen regierung dürfte jetzt aber
einiges in diese richtung in bewegung
kommen
äußerlich deutet bei unserem besuch in
tiflis noch nichts auf den politischen
erdrutsch in der sich ein paar wochen
später bei den parlamentswahlen ereignen
wäre der könig ist nackt heißt es hier
weil präsident saakaschwili im
vergangenen frühjahr mit dem
geschäftsmann iwanischwili einen
politischen konkurrenten erhalten hat
hier thront der widersacher erwartet
werde ich von georgien persönlichen
berater des milliardärs wer ist der 56
jährige bettina war nicht wie der mann
auf den jetzt viele georgierinnen und
georgier ihre hoffnung setzen
er hat in russland erfolgreich mit
computern und telefongeräte geschäftet
und später eine eigene kreditbank
gegründet geschichten um mafiöse
geschäfte banken erstaunlicherweise
keine um seine person seine politischen
gegner hätten aus solchen bestimmt gerne
kapital geschlagen
die war nicht spiele ist sofort bereit
mich doch sein geschäftszentrum zu
führen
hier habe ich mir einen
multifunktionellen saal eingerichtet der
boden hier kann gewogen abgesenkt und
gedreht werden
der raum eignet sich für kleine konzerte
oder auch für theater dort unten können
sich die schauspieler einkleiden
für sie gibt es hier auch einen
speziellen lift diese residenz dienen
vor allem als geschäftszentrum man
präsentationen vorführen und
pressekonferenzen abhalten können
wir blicken runter auf den
präsidentenpalast wo iwanischwili es
intimfeind sackers wie die residiert mit
dem präsidenten habe er gebrochen als
sich dieser vor viereinhalb jahren sehr
zum schaden des landes ins
kriegsabenteuer mit russland eingelassen
habe der krieg vom sommer 2008 hätte
verhindert werden können
statt sich auf dieses abenteuer
einzulassen
hätte er internationale beobachter rufen
sollen er hätte vorübergehend ein paar
familien aus den bedrohten dörfern weg
bringen müssen und der konflikt hätte
bald gelöst werden können saakaschwili
java hat flugzeuge und panzer eingesetzt
hat selbst attackiert und so so hat er
schließlich alles kaputt gemacht er hat
sich schlimm und dumm verhalten
deshalb so der iwanischwili sei jetzt
gezwungen gewesen selbst in die
politische arena zu steigen
ich möchte gerne allen im land helfen
aber meine größte hilfe ist nicht das
geld das ich aus gebe sondern dass ich
mich dazu entschieden habe in die
politik einzusteigen
diese entscheidung ist mir schwer
gefallen denn politik entspricht
letztlich nicht mein charakter
bis jetzt haben sie vor allem geld
verteilt einfach verteilt kann sowas
wirklich sinnvoll sein das ganze dorf in
dem ich aufgewachsen bin war arm
die menschen lebten von einer ernte zu
anderen unsere kinder schule wurden
zuerst vom ältesten getragen dann von
einem jüngeren bruder dann von mir meine
hosen und hemden sind zig mal geflickt
worden
wir waren trotzdem glücklich ja meine
kindheit war nicht weniger glücklich als
die meine kinder allein macht nicht
wirklich
es gibt eine gewisse freiheit wenn man
es richtig einsetzt aber man darf nicht
dessen sklave
[Musik]
wir brechen auf nach ávila ins
heimatdorf des milliardärs
[Musik]
willkommen im reich von könig
iwanischwili in seinem heimatort robi
lack oder wie man hier sagt das kleine
paris sein neues prächtiges anwesend
bezogen 2002 als er aus russland
zurückkehrte
in horrweiler floss das manga des
milliardärs bisher am besten
der könig ließ umgehend alle häuser im
dorf renovieren oder neu bauen und
verwirklichte so seinen großen
georgischen traum erst mal im kleinen
heute ist designkiosk doch früher lebten
viele familien im dorf in solchen wagen
containern ohne strom und ohne wasser
für die 60.000 einwohner im bezirk st
lebt es sich besser als im übrigen armen
georgien
hier haben fast alle ein neues dach über
dem kopf sowie der bauart ariel mit
seiner familie noch vor wenigen jahren
war sein hof völlig verlottert wie alles
in der gegend eines tages wusste er
nicht mehr wie ihm geschah es war der
tag als er seinen ehemaligen
klassenkameraden traf inzwischen
mehrfacher milliardär ohne ihn sagt uns
bauer tage würden hier alle not leiden
um den der fälle leben
[Musik]
szenisch wie hat dir alles gemacht
ich hatte kein dach gar nichts alles war
kaputt
dann sind wir uns zufällig begegnet und
ich habe ihn gebeten oder besser er hat
mich gefragt was mir fehle
ich antwortete meine kinder schlafen auf
beton
da hat er mir am selben tag sein
verwalter geschickt wie ziener ist mein
freund meint lassen kann
er ist alles für mich er hat hier alles
gemacht ich habe in meinem leben auch
schon ein wenig geld verdient aber so
etwas hätte ich mir nie leisten können
dieses zimmer sah aus wie eine bruchbude
alles war alt und da hat uns das so
schön renoviert für ihn würde ich mich
erschießen lassen
die war nie spiele wuchs in dieser
gegend auf sein vermögen machte er im
boomenden moskau der 90er jahre 2002
kehrte er zurück doch bis vor einem jahr
zeigte er sich nie in der öffentlichkeit
zwar gibt es sie noch die tristesse des
zerfalls die armut und arbeitslosigkeit
aber neu gibt es hier auch hoffnung
insgesamt soll die spiele in ganz
georgien bereits 100000 jobs geschaffen
haben
auch hinter bezirkshauptstadt satz ging
plötzlich des neuen königs geldregen
nieder
das ist wikia die rechte hand des
oligarchen sein verwalter hier im
gebäude des iwanischwili
wohltätigkeitsfonds sozusagen dem
inoffiziellen stadthaus kepler ist die
anlaufstelle für jene die zu kurz kommen
und das sind fast alle lehrer rentner
und kinderreiche familien
der staat hilft auch ein wenig aber das
ist miserabel
damit kann man unmöglich leben wir
zahlen zusätzliche gelder aus unserem
fonds und helfen allen im bezirk doch
der reichste mann georgiens verteilt
nicht nur geld in seinem bezirk er
finanziert zahllose projekte für ihr
auch gleich die nötigen fabrikanlagen
baut hier werden die neuen becher
fabriziert mit denen er in satirisch und
12.000 von 16.000 häuser neu decken dies
für die zahllosen von ihm finanzierten
straßen und gebäude schufa flugs eine
asphalt und beton fabrik wo jahrelang
alles vor die hunde gehen gibt es nun
neue schulhäuser gepflegte trottoirs und
ein neues ladenzentrum könig benziner
schenkte den bezirk gar ein neues spital
gratis für alle einwohner und die ärzte
müsse nicht mehr gesprochen werden
sie bekommen einen anständigen lohn es
ist fast so wie die kommunisten es immer
versprachen aber nie einlöste
in rohr villa bekommt jede familie
fernseher kühlschrank und waschmaschine
geschenkt die einwohnerzahl hat sich
verdoppelt verrät uns mäppchen alle
jungen leute sind zurückgekehrt nach
rohr villa denn sie haben hier jeden
komfort
alle wollen ja gut leben und so leben
sie eben da wo es viel besser ist als
anderswo
und alle wollen mädchen von hier
heiraten ja alle männer wollen das heute
findest du hier kein einziges
unverheiratetes mädchen alle heiraten
[Musik]
eine rauschende georgische hochzeit
finanziert von wie könnte es anders sein
bettina wie die dorfbewohner ihren
gönner iwanischwili liebevoll nennen
niemand im saal hinterfragt iwanischwili
scanner tätigkeit
nein sie vertrauen ihm und das ist wohl
des königs größter reichtum
zurück in tiflis wie ein guter könig ist
iwanischwili um das wohl seines volkes
besorgt und er sichert sich so ganz
nebenbei dessen unterstützung
wenn ich an die macht kommen werde ich
alles verändern
dann bauen wir ein richtiges fundament
richtung europa ein fundament das gute
arbeitsplätze schafft wir brauchen
vernünftige ökonomische verhältnisse ihm
der sich in der rolle des wohltäters
gefällt aber auch wirklich gelingen wird
die situation im ganzen land zu
verbessern ist derzeit eine noch sehr
offene frage das ist mein lieblingsbild
es ist von lucio das war wohl sehr teuer
ich habe etwa 35 millionen dollar dafür
bezahlt sie als privatperson
wie ist denn ihr verhältnis zur kunst
ich habe viel geld verdient aber nie mit
dem ziel milliardär zu werden
ich hatte mir ein system aufgebaut das
geld eingebracht hat entsprechend fällt
es mir auch leicht geld auszugeben
ich gebe mindestens 90 prozent für die
allgemeinheit aus behalte maximal zehn
prozent für mich selbst wenn ich nicht
am baum bin gebe ich nur ein bis zwei
prozent für mich selbst aus
[Musik]
die bilder sollen wie könnte es anders
sein der einst in einem der
öffentlichkeit zum nicht museum hängen
wie ein richtiges märchen hat auch diese
geschichte vorläufig kein happy end
jeweilig schwieriges parteienbündnis
georgischer traum ist bei den
parlamentswahlen von oktober als grosse
siegerin hervorgegangen
ein paar wochen nach unserem besuch ist
bettina ja nicht schwierig zum neuen
regierungschef gekürt worden und
aufgrund einer neuen
verfassungsbestimmung ist er jetzt auch
der politisch mächtigste mann in
georgien noch vor dem staatspräsidenten
wir verlassen die georgische hauptstadt
tiflis und farb ostwärts weiter
doch kaffee ziehen oder georgische wein
wächst an der idyllisch gelegene
bergstadt signal die vorbei an die
grenze nach aserbaidschan
in aserbaidschan in unserer nächsten
folge besuchen wir eine fabrik wo
seidenstoffe und teppiche mit großer
kunstfertigkeit geworben werden
wir begegnen dem schwarzen gold dem öl
das einerseits der gesundheit dienen
kann und dass der wirtschaft des landes
einen massiven schub verleiht und wir
sehen den lichtzauber in der
aserbaidschanischen hauptstadt baku
[Applaus]
[Musik]